but why don't we go ahead and get
started with our bellows lecture this is
such a highlight for the year for the
school it's such a part of our tradition
and we've had such a wonderful speakers
over the years and today is certainly no
exception um we then always have of
course the reception afterwards the
whisser tea and of course there's
history and story to that as well and
and stan is happy about the t because
he's an anglophile
but we will have the reception
following um it's such an honor and a
personal pleasure for me to be able to
introduce to you dr sten vermond dean of
the school of public health seth and i
go way way back when i was a little
student and he was a baby faculty
back in new york city back in the days
when the the hiv pandemic was starting
sten is a
yale
and national resource
trained as a pediatrician
obviously a public health expert and i'm
going to say an honorary nurse
he has always gotten the power of public
health and nursing working together
since done it all okay so sure he's uh
he's an infectious epidemiologist we all
knew that we've all seen him on on the
media and as he's respond help yale
respond to covid during this pandemic
he's a pediatrician by by training and
and practice and i think those of you
who are pediatricians and adolescent
medicine will appreciate that that
clinical perspective
he's focused on improving care
in
every setting i'm going to say he has
worked in multiple countries around the
world always thinking about how do we
get to equity which of course is our
theme
at yale school of nursing
he's worked on hiv hpv tb parasitic
diseases
and of course coronavirus just just a
handful of the pathogens that he has has
brought
his his uh bearing and his expertise to
and collaborations with so many people
around the world
he is interested in interventional
science and he led the hiv prevention
trials network for many years a huge
endeavor
and so that has really moved the needle
on a lot of our hiv prevention clinical
trials
and implementation science which is a
theme also here at yale and it's always
about as we care about as nurses
increasing coverage quality evidence and
impact of care
he he has as i say experience in the
real world
in academia and also in nih and so those
of you who may have been around during
the hiv
pandemic he was one of those incredible
bridge people
who could work with the activists people
living with hiv who were dying
who were trying to make change and how
do we do science so that people can
survive
he came up with the first women's cohort
hiv women's cohort
i think i remember you being on stage
with jim curran and the activists were
throwing toilet paper at you all
and you just kept speaking you heard the
concerns and change was made in the way
we do science and what you did at nih
very very incredible
of course in this most recent period
as stan has been leading the school of
public health our sister's school he
also pivoted towards covert 19 research
um including working with collaborators
in china and around the world um he
worked with the economist here on just
these are just some examples of on mass
use
safety with schools and arts
organizations in new york city new york
as well as in connecticut
and he has really continued all that
work along with his incredible faculty
who are collaborators of our many of
ours at the school of public health he's
of course um
has reached the pinnacle of achievements
in in being recognized for his his
science and his contribution he's
elected member of the national academy
of medicine fellow of the american
association for the advancement of
science i'm sure i'm missing a lot of
accolades um but really the most
important thing is he's a genuinely kind
and
smart
and warm collaborator he he champions
people he wants everyone to be doing um
good work and he helps support us all on
doing that including thinking about
nursing and public health partnerships
so he's embodied that
as the dean of the school of public
health um he was instrumental with us as
we formed the yale institute for global
health remembering that the three of our
schools really launched that and so i
didn't announce this to you before
stents but rather than getting you a
yale bowl or yale pen we're going to
plant a tree for you
and that will be our gift to even thank
you for speaking today particularly
given the topic which is the topic of
our time and that tree someday will grow
and shelter and be filled and turned
into a bowl for someone else but for you
it'll be the tree thank you you thank
you
thank you very much
[Applause]
well that was very kind very generous
and i'm really thrilled to be here
i came shortly after my arrival in 2017
over to the school
marveled at your space
salivated
and uh was really uh impressed with what
you were doing in the school that was
the time you were you were doing your
simulation labs you were building them
and there was just so much vibrancy and
excitement in the school and there still
is to this day
so i'm bringing a relatively familiar uh
uh topic to you so i hope i can um give
it some some novelty and uh a little bit
of perspective so what we're going to
try to do is take a look at the
latest data i could find
um and uh and just remind you that prior
climatologic predictions from greenhouse
gas release have actually understated
true effects this is if we've learned
anything in the last 12 months
it's that all of these dire predictions
it's the upper
95 confidence interval that we're
tracking not the middle certainly not
the low
so we'll review a few climatologic
highlights discuss mitigation efforts
uh implications for human health for
example strategies for adaptation to
planetary warming
uh relevance for loss of habitat species
diversities uh diversity comment on
human population growth and we'll end
with a comment about nursing as a vital
element for climate change adaptation
now
um it took me i'm not quite the guru in
this topic that anne is
uh and and i would muddle my use of the
word mitigation and adaptation i'm going
to put it out there just because i
learned it now if i'm a
carbon capture engineer
or if i'm somebody working on policy to
guide us to set our thermostats properly
or to massively improve
uh solar power or
improve the efficiency of machinery so
it uses less energy than i'm mitigating
climate change
but if i'm just a pediatrician
with a background infectious
epidemiology and
i'm looking at
uh island nations that are being
inundated or i'm looking at
malaria zones that are expanding and i'm
trying to help cope with that that's
adaptation
so what we really want is we want
mitigation
but guess what we nurses public health
professionals docs and health providers
have to worry about adaptation because
that's our space that's the space where
we think we can actually make a
difference
so let me make sure i can get this to
work
and here you've seen this before many of
you
from 1880 to
2021
uh the the more yellow and the more red
the greater the deviants from historic
norms and take a look at the polls how
much red pops up at the polls
and
i guess we're at
1990 now
and we're coming to 2000 and 2010
and 2021.
oops
didn't mean to show it twice okay so the
annual mean surface temperature anomaly
is what the meteorologists refer to
when they're doing these historic
temperature uh gradient comparisons
and the past eight years have been the
warmest in recorded history
as per the world meteorological
association and
organization and as per everybody else
no matter who is analyzing this they all
say the same thing even with different
methods the last eight years have been
modern history's warmest eight years
there are record levels of heat trapping
atmospheric greenhouse gases
the global temperature about 1.1 degrees
higher than uh historic norms and you
know that we're trying with paris
climate change to keep it to under 1.5
and
we're not going to get there actually
but we need to work today to make sure
we
keep it under two
so um
this is the seventh consecutive year
where global temperature has been more
than one degree uh
celsius above pre-industrial levels and
you know the consequences are massive
loss of sea ice and
ice sheet mass sea level rise
we've got longer more intense heat waves
and major habitat changes affecting
humans and animals and plants alike and
i'm just straining to see so the upper
map is global temperature trends 1901
to 2017
and the lower map is 1988 to 2017.
so
just to give you a sense of the
comparative
analysis
and the greenhouse gas trends are
unremittingly grim up up up
so here's another uh fancy uh
sten can barely cope
video okay so now we start in 2002
and we take a look at the greenland ice
mass loss
over
about a 19-year period
and we'll be coming up to 2020.
and this is green
greenland ice loss
and meters equivalent uh relative to
2002.
and when we when we're measuring here
this this y-axis is mass loss in
gigatons now i personally have no
concept of a gigaton
other than it's a heck of a lot of ice
that's my technical interpretation of a
gigaton it's a massive amount of ice and
one one more time
and this is uh antarctic ice mass that
was greenland now we have antarctic
antarctica and this is from 2002
to 2019
and um taking another look at uh 150
gigatons of lost ice mass per year
what happens is that these these sort of
glacial
features are almost like the um stopper
on a bottle and when you take the
stopper off by
by
by melting
and you you might have the separation of
a distal part of the glacier the rest of
the glacier starts to move even faster
you've taken that bottle off that bottle
top off so that's what we're facing and
you may be aware
that we had about two was it two three
years ago and uh the um the calving
of a huge uh component
of um
of antarctica the size of the state of
rhode island
us
now that did not do much for
uh global um sea level rise because it
was already essentially floating
but it's separated now and now it will
melt and then it will contribute
and we're we're we're running into
massive shifts that the climatologists
really can't even believe
now that's just mount kilimanjaro the
tallest amount mountain in uh in africa
if you're my age you actually uh read uh
hemingway as a kid these short stories
and then you saw the movie with gregory
peck and
and susan hayward and ava gardner the
snows of kilimanjaro there are no more
snows on kilimanjaro
so you look at um 20 1912 you look at
1970
2000 and 2007 and this is
sort of schematically represented over
to the right and the
snow mass on the top of kilimanjaro is
relatively trivial
as a consequence uh in the warming of
the entire region
um this used to be the part of kenya
where the colonialists would go to avoid
malaria in the hot season
well now you have malaria all the way up
halfway up kilimanjaro you cut you can
get malaria and that's because of
expanded um
vector breeding opportunities because
it's warmer and uh moisture there's also
been a lot of deforestation
and so you throw that in and you have a
lot of trouble in this region
now the most terrifying of all the
slides we'll get to the optimistic size
later that's what we're going to all do
about this but the most terrifying slide
is this one the thermohaline circulation
particularly in the atlantic current the
so-called meridional overturning
circulation of the mock
now
these are the giant
rivers within the oceans if you want to
look at it that way
so
deep down you have cold water currents
they rise as they come into
the tropics and then they return
as warm water currents the most famous
famous of which is the gulf stream so if
you look at the gulf stream up here take
a look at just how far north
i think i have a pointer
i
can't can't get see it anyway you know
where norway is where my parents came
from and and and iceland and take a look
at how far north that is that's
greenland that's siberia that's northern
canada okay
now why can people live in iceland and
norway it's all about the gulf stream
that's why those are habitable countries
they're way too far north
to be uh habitable in a in a in a
productive way so what's happened is for
the first time in recorded history we've
measured the slowing of these currents
and nobody
on planet earth has a clue as to what
that might mean
we do know that there has been
systematic warming of uh and and
bleaching of reefs because of warming so
the corals are adapted to slightly
cooler water you warm it up they die
and it's also true that we've seen
massive displacements of fish
populations
as they as they seek cooler waters
closer to their you know millennially
adapted
physiologies
so
this could be the most important
consequence of global climate change if
we actually see the substantial
disruption of these currents because we
really don't know how this could
disrupt the ecosystems of the globe so
here are the health issues direct
effects of heat
you know we have hotter and drier
summers and we can have heat related
deaths
we have warmer and wetter winters as a
consequence with with the consequence of
loss of polar and glacialized we have
increased extreme weather events
we have property and crop loss
and we have loss of
reef ecosystems which disrupts fish
yields so you can see the direct effects
on our food chain and especially among
the elderly and the very young who are
much more susceptible to things like
heat stroke and you may recall in europe
it was about 15 years ago it was a
massive
atypical european heat wave and it's
estimated that uh 20 000 or so
elderly in europe whose air conditioners
were not working or who didn't have air
conditioners and they called the air
conditioning supply company and nobody
came because they were overwhelmed with
other calls and they essentially cooked
in their apartments and that is has
happened to a lesser degree in the u.s
but it's the kind of thing that we can
anticipate so are we as nurses as uh in
this case maybe not pediatrician but for
the kids uh are we as geriatricians are
we going to
um start start taking seriously uh how
well networked our elderly are
in times of stress and emergency are we
going to actually have plans
to cope with heat waves and the
inevitability that one in 20
air conditioner is going to break down
during this period and isn't going to be
fixed because the companies are
overwhelmed are we going to plan for
this these are the sorts of adaptation
issues that we have to think about and
there are plenty of direct heat effects
that we're going to have to worry about
perhaps the most dramatic example of a
direct heat effect is desertification
so the
sahara desert is moving south
in the sahel region of africa at least
100 kilometers per year
and that is displacing the grazers and
farmers who have lived in these in these
sahel
border regions with the with the desert
and this is the kind of
phenomenon you'll see when you go there
people having abandoned their dying
animals and having to migrate
tremendous stress
and if the vegetation animals aren't
going to survive the people have to move
now we have this climatologic
displacement climate refugees that i
just alluded to with my desertification
slide and extreme weather events which
also are going to
face um
resulting in internally displaced people
and sometimes even refugees across
across borders that's the kind of
definition if you cross borders you're a
refugee if you're if you're displaced
within your own country or an indus
internally displaced person just for the
vocabulary now i find this website uh to
be fascinating the alliance of small
island states this is 35 countries and
five territories including all of ours
members of of the territories of this
organization include puerto rico
american virgin islands uh maria
northern marianas islands uh american
samoa and guam those are the the five
territories in the united states and
they're all members of this
so what they are worried about is their
existence
now take a look at what two different
modelers using two different strategies
did
uh in in modeling what will happen with
one meter uh uh ocean rise
in florida in the next 30 years and um
uh next 50 years i think it is and this
is one modeler and the the ecological
devastation that the entire everglades
are going to be swamped with with with
salt water it can't be understated i
mean
that'll that'll be a dead zone uh and
then some very valuable real estate
including all of the kennedy space
center will be underwater and this
modeler the one to the right
is much more pessimistic
much much greater um um
uh saturation of
of seawater into the state of florida
now we will spend
billions and billions and billions and
hundreds maybe of billions of dollars to
build sea walls and mitigate this
so when we say we can't afford to tackle
climate change
that's because people are thinking in
two three-year economic windows they're
not thinking in 20 30-year economic
windows
now
as temperatures rise more and more water
vapor evaporates into the atmosphere
that is fuel for storms as any
climatologist will tell you
and the more heat and water in the
atmosphere with warmer ocean surface
temperatures increases
storm wind speeds and their analogous
temperature phenomena uh on land which
increased the uh
strength of tornadoes
so uh so we can expect um uh
greenhouse gas emissions and global
warming to result in more extreme
weather events and we've already seen it
now keep in mind too
that snow reflects heat it's white
reflects
whereas rock absorbs it dark absorbs it
absorb it you learned that in grade
school
and with fresh water snowpack and
glacial losses loss of snowpack loss of
glaciers earlier rain rain on snow
we are going to see new cycles of floods
and then droughts and i'll i'll i'll
circle back to that in a few slides
and the costs of these events are vast
there are 15 atlantic current hurricanes
that have cost at least uh 10 billion
dollars each of damage
and the
king and queen of these hurricanes
were katrina
in new orleans
and harvey
in houston
each of which
resulted in 125 billion dollars worth of
damage
and
it just is a miracle to me that our
political leaders
argue that we can't afford to mitigate
and adapt to climate change
uh when we're incurring these kinds of
costs and we will be incurring vast new
costs for
dubious technologies like
like like sea walls that may or may not
work
now vector-borne diseases this is sort
of more my field and uh in our school we
do a lot of work in this space
and that's a long list and i hate
lecturers who give you slides with long
lists but i couldn't resist
just to let you know that you've got
mosquito related infections because
mosquitoes remember if if if if the
mosquito is here and i'm malarious
it has to bite me
then it has to live the sexual lifestyle
life life uh of course of the of the uh
of the
malaria parasite which is now
the male and female
are
are finding themselves in the in the uh
in the uh the sporozoites uh are going
to mature after the oso cysts mature in
the mid gut that takes
eight to 12 days depending upon the
species so the mosquito is not going to
infect anne if it doesn't live eight to
12 days
but if we help it live eight to 12 days
by being warmer and moister
then a greater proportion of all the
malaria mosquitoes will survive to
infect others so you can see how that
could have radical
rise in
malarial incidents
similarly arboviruses and many other
vector related infections
in which black flies like warm moist
uh environments so do snails so do
rodents so did see flies and reduved
bugs so do ticks
and you can even have
water that is warmer
for a longer period of time that might
harbor cholera and other
water-borne disease for a longer time so
that's
the story and here's zimbabwe
where to you know 10 years ago
those were the
highlands which were largely malaria
free
and um 30 years from now there will be
no malaria-free zones of the nation
they will all be hyper-endemic or even
holoendemic for
malaria whole endemic being one
one
notch even more intense in terms of
transmission than hyperendemic
then we have population pressures and
shrinking
land
and
water assets that also includes
fish assets
now this slide comes from lake victoria
and you recall that that's
a lake that borders uganda kenya and
tanzania
and
if you look at 1960
and take a look at the at the population
density
and then you go all the way forward to
2015
you'll see massive uh population growth
and pressures on the lake
and the fisher folk
who live around lake victoria and make
their living
supplying protein
rich fish to the population
they are now harvesting smaller and
smaller and smaller fish
it's exactly what happened in the grand
banks off of newfoundland
the richest cod fishing
uh zones in the entire world that were
fished out about 30 years ago and have
never rebounded the codfish have never
rebounded the grand banks which was
mind-boggling to those of us who
remember that from our childhood where
that was the teeming source of cod fish
and
uh and now you don't you don't fish for
cod in the grand bank so there is neymar
cut
and the prospect of overfishing
over grazing
on the land deforestation farmland
pressures
is almost certainly going to result in
hunger and climate refugees in this very
intensively
populated part of the world and guess
what we're repeating this story
in um
lake after lake after lake ecosystem all
around the world where population
pressures are severely affecting here's
the aral c
and the historic aral sea is what all
the blue represents and the current is
just
this dark blue and you can see how the
historic
was this vast area in the current is is
like this that gentleman
is standing
where the sea used to lap where where
where the where the where the sea used
to reach
and there's an uh
a navy worth of
vessels
that are completely abandoned because
not only is there much less water in the
aerial sea
but it's now saline water for all
practical purposes
uh great salt lake kind of thing
and there are no fish in the aerial sea
that can be harvested this is from crop
growing uh in which the uh
rivers were diverted to feed the very um
water
thirsty cotton plants
and extensive use of pesticides and
fertilizers most of which end up in the
aerial sea eventually poisoning the fish
now the exact same same phenomenon is
happening
in lake chad which is a fraction of its
size
uh
chad niger nigeria
it's it's estimated to be about half the
size that it has been historically
and
those of you who have some california
roots i went to i went to high school in
college in california
the
mono lake
used to be this is a vibrant large lake
in northern california it's it's it's a
wasteland now because all that water was
used for
um
urban water supplies and uh did not have
adequate uh restoration capacity
now um
you can't mention water
lakes
grazing without mentioning uh forests
because if you go to ten thousand years
ago or five thousand years ago
more than half the the habitable
habitable planet so 77 of the globe was
habitable so get rid of antarctica and
the arctic et cetera and get rid of the
highest mountains of the himalayas and
look at the rest that was 77 so this is
this represents 100 of the 77 percent of
which more than half where it was forest
even in 1700 more than half was forest
it fell to below half by the time we had
a billion people on earth in 1900
and you had eight percent uh uh being
used for crops and sixteen percent for
grazing and that has doubled in a little
more than a hundred years so now we're
using 15
for crops uh and 31 for grazing land and
i don't know if this surprise is you but
it sure surprised me
if you'd given me a quiz and said
you know
get this answer right or i'm
confiscating your you know favorite pet
i would have bet on uh on uh on grazing
on cropland being more than grazing land
but grazing land is more than double
and a lot of deforestation is happening
to accommodate our thirst for meat
our hunger for meat would be a better
term
and that is kind of what we're looking
at in a just in a um
a 48-hour period those are the active
fires going on in latin america
and um and you can see how the amazon is
is deforested and then burned to prepare
it for grazing and for crops
now
um
i have offended people in audiences with
this slide it's from the un
and i want to explain it clearly
so the united nations estimates that 222
million women who live in low and
middle-income countries
would like to have access to
contraception but they do not have
access
that's what we mean by unmet need for
contraception we're not talking about
coercing anybody
we're not even talking about convincing
anybody this is when you ask would you
like to space your children
and not have a child every year would
you like to control the fertility within
your family structure and they say yes
and do you have access to contraception
so you can control your fertility they
say no would you like it yes that's
unmet need
if we
if we could meet that unmet need
that would handle demand in
50 million of persons under the age of
25.
14 million of them are under the age of
20.
and uh
1652 million of them are in the world's
poorest countries
where you have the least capacity to
have a family of 10 or 12.
that would prevent 63 million unintended
pregnancies and it would prevent 19
million unsafe abortions
and it would also save 82 000
mothers lives directly
so
education and sustainable economic
empowerment especially for girls and
women does a lot to advance
control of fertility we've seen that in
study after study internationally there
are exceptions
where for example you have very strong
pronatal sentiments
uh
orthodox religions for example uh of
various sorts uh where there's a very
strong desire to have very large
families so then then the education and
economic empowerment
formula doesn't quite work but in every
other environment it works very well so
there's a vast unmet need
and uh keep in mind that when i was born
in 1954 there were 2.7 billion people on
earth and now there are 7.9 billion
people on earth
and it took us
100 years to double the population
previously
and it's taken us half of 100 years to
increase it almost threefold so
we either take global population control
seriously or we don't
we don't take it seriously
then you're going to have a lot of
underfed children
uh in families that are
not able to support six seven eight nine
ten children
and didn't want that number of children
there's a lot of individual and
community tragedy but there's also an
existential threat to
planet earth
because
reasonable people have argued
that
7.9 billion people is too many people
for a good quality of life for people on
earth and we can do a lot if all we do
is
meet unmet need
so i dwelled on this slide to make sure
you understand my point of view
i am not looking to coerce anybody
no one child policy no nothing
just meet the need of women who want
contraception meet that need and we will
do a lot to get
turn turn to the right direction so
let's take a look at events in the past
two years
2020 2021 we had australian and western
usa wildfires that were the worst in the
history of those two countries by far
the largest the most intense
we had tremendous challenges in smoke
exposure and poor air quality
and we had a lot of mental health
impacts
people who lost everything lost their
homes
some people lost lives of loved ones
firefighters were lost on and on
i've already mentioned the temperature
records of the past eight years being
the hottest ever but they're also
local venue
hottest day ever records that have been
broken
in a historic sweep
from siberia all the way to arizona and
florida
uh places that had broke their records
by
uh
five degrees fahrenheit 10 degrees
fahrenheit there was one place in
siberia that broke the record by 40
degrees fahrenheit
and
2020 and 2016 were the hottest years in
recorded history although
2020 isn't that different from 2021 in
fact they were judged to be virtually
indistinguishable
kovit had an interesting result which
was a favorable impact on
greenhouse gas emissions
because there was less driving there was
less industry and the like
but the impact on food supply chains
were very complex
some places were not severely impacted
other places were severely impacted so
they're all
i can't exactly cheer for covid having
done us much good because a lot of these
are now rebounding to historic uh levels
of greenhouse gas emissions
finally we'll talk about evolving
drought and flood cycles and famine risk
so this is a map
where they are
showing the
size of glacial regions in the himalaya
and the
loss in um glacial size is represented
by the red color
if it's white color no change and if
it's blue a little bit of addition so
overwhelmingly
loss especially in the glaciers that are
closest to population areas that are
that are feeding
the
indus river
the brahmaputra ganges river and the
mekong river deltas now
1.5 billion people live in these deltas
and what is now happening
is early three three week shorter
snowpack
and earlier
melting
and
earlier springtime
flooding
and later
summer drought
so it's not actually a net decline or
increase in
total precipitation it's a it's it's
more rain less snow
and earlier um
snowpack melt and glacial melt
with greater volumes in the rivers early
in season and then drought volumes later
in the season
and
none of this is good news none of this
suggests
that we are going to have farmers
and villagers better off with these
conditions than they've been
historically they're going to be worse
off
with
early floods late droughts
here is borneo over about a 19-year
period
and if it's green it means forest and if
it's orange it means no forest
and to the right you have northeast
brazil if it's blue-green
it's forest loss if it's red there's
forest different kind of
infrared photography
and um to the left it's because of
deforestation and uh population
pressures uh grazing and
and um
a little bit of uh oil um
uh exploration
uh not a little bit in certain areas a
lot of it and to the right it's all
mining
of course i could have taken a big
different picture from from brazil in
the amazon it would have been due to
deforestation so there is a lot going on
in our world that is not favorable now
the good news
with a research policy education
action this is both feasible and
necessary we can confront global climate
change at the same time
take a look at issues of
uh loss of biodiversity on our planet
and
human overpopulation
so um efficient transportation looms
very large
we are um
burning um
fossil fuels when we could be
uh using solar power
so three years ago my wife and i went
solar in our house
cost us thirty three thousand dollars we
got about ten thousand back from our
taxes in the feds and we got about three
thousand back from the state so that was
a net of twenty thousand dollars we pay
virtually no
uh just the hookup fee
and we bought an electric car so our
electric cars is powered by our
solar panels
and
are we going to change the history of
planet earth by no means
but i'm hoping we might influence our
neighbors
and i'm hoping you might do the same in
my influence your neighbors in other
words there has to be
some level of tipping point where some
of us get ahead of the curve
um and uh you know
um
take a take a risk on new technology
because it's not new anymore solar
panels prices have plummeted
and it really is very favorable if your
home happens to be properly suited
suited you know some people live in the
middle of the forest and short of
cutting down a bunch of trees it won't
work but many of us have some solar
exposure and we can go solar so that's
at the micro level but at the macro
level you can do what bishops farms how
many of you have had a pie from bishops
out in guilford they are completely
carbon neutral
it's not because they're buying carbon
credits they've become carbon neutral
because they've deployed a number of
their
um
of their orchards
and they have turned them into solar
farms
so all of the energy utilization of um
yeah i think they have some
gas
but they're selling enough they're
installing enough
energy solar energy into the grid to
balance that
um
we can do so much more here at yale
my building the leph building many of
you know 60 colleges
is
[Music]
out of 150
buildings on campus that had energy
audits was the 15th least
energy efficient
i'm ashamed to walk into that building
every single day and they've done some
mitigation
remediation i should say in a i think
we're not quite that bad but they
haven't done the definitive the
definitive things
and we can power electric cars buses
trains there's nothing stopping us now
we have the technology
energy conservation
the notion of having it at 68
in the winter and 72 in the summer is
not that big a sacrifice but people
don't do it
and it just enrages me when i go into a
public space in the summer and i i'm
sorry i forgot my my my sweater because
we just keep it the europeans think
we're nuts
because they don't do that
and you go into a hotel in europe in the
middle of the winter and you better have
a sweater because it's a little chilly
and you go in the summer it's going to
be a little bit warmer maybe than you're
used to but we just have to
um adapt we're just we're just wasting
energy we have double the energy
utilization of the average american than
the average european
we have automatic shutoffs we have led
buildings that we ought to be
uh promulgating we have many other
sustainable energy sources
and i put nuclear in yellow just to
just to stimulate conversation later
and economic incentives captain cap and
trade carbon credits tax credits and the
whole notion of sustainable land use and
population stabilization do we really
have to eat as much meat as we do do we
really have to have as much grazing land
as we have
couldn't we
take advantage of the fact that it takes
10 kilos of plant protein
to grow one kilo of meat protein
couldn't we eat some of that plant
protein instead
the answer is of course
now political change and commitment is
essential and we
we need better leadership
there was a moratorium on fossil fuel
exploration with massive shift
alternating alternative energy sources
how many of you noticed the announcement
last week from the biden administration
opening up hundreds of thousands of
acres of land for
oil exploration again
and
that i call the ukraine policy setback
and i put that in yellow because that
might be of interest to us to discuss in
a moment commitment to conservation with
policy shifts as i mentioned you know
we've had tremendous success
changing tobacco attitudes changing
uh drinking under the influence
attitudes
um
um you know you you don't smoke in
airplanes anymore you don't smoke in
buildings anymore and we've seen and we
have
much higher tobacco taxes and we've seen
tobacco use drop
we can create we can work with our
economy friends our economist friends
and we can create incentives to make it
more expensive for you to pollute and
less expensive for you not to pollute
and if we don't do it we're in trouble
we need
aggressive preservation of wild places
to enhance biodiversity and mitigate co2
release reforestation control pesticide
use and pollution and there were a lot
of good advice coming out of the glasgow
conference i'm proud to say yaylee um
colleague of ours
[Music]
uh secretary kerry
is uh
spearheading this now as the
international climate change at the
cabinet level i might have and we
couldn't ask for a better voice
now the emergency response and planning
this is something that's in our
bailiwick as nurses as as planners
public health folks
we need to anticipate heat waves drought
and extreme weather modeling
forecasting
relocation of persons doing the flooding
and storm we can we can
we can plan
for the
unknown knowns
we know it's going to happen we don't
know when
but we can plan for it so that when it
happens we're ready
what about if we had taken the advice of
the cdc in 2017 when they came out with
updates of their pandemic influenza
prevention plans
which was like a road map for what we
should be doing to get ready for covid
we just didn't know it was coveted
but it was largely ignored and largely
set on a shelf and then we had covet and
we weren't ready we knew what to do we
just weren't ready
incentivize and improve the appeal of
vegetable-based diets the head of yale
hospitality here is incredibly
creative
he has
he and his experts have lopped off half
of the meat consumption of yale
undergraduates over the last five years
with an area peep
through creative
use of vegetables
creative um
menus and um strategies for making foods
appealing that are largely plant driven
and he can do it we can do it in our
households and we can do it in our
institutional settings
and control of air and water pollution
is a no-brainer
vector control bed nuts community
engagement that's a big one because
we've got to educate
water and hygiene innovation the old
drip technologies that the israelis
taught us 60 years ago
in the kibbutz
protect the environment uh retain
ecological diversity and the
contraception
agenda
so um
the kids know we've got to do something
greta thundberg
the south africans uh have faced this in
a big way there's my favorite bishops
orchard
and uh here are divestment protesters
saying
yeah yale with your 44 billion endowment
do you really have to be owning fossil
fuel companies really
can't you be a
role model for others
and this i want to end with habitat loss
is a major threat to biodiversity i've
kind of gone over my time i think am i
right
i'm okay okay well that's a miracle so
um
habitat degradation
uh exploitation
invasive species pollution climate
change those are what are affecting fish
mammals reptiles and amphibians and
birds now
and you can just expect the climate
change blue to grow and grow and grow
so this is kind of
10 years ago and it's just going to get
worse on the climate change side so
we've already had tremendous threats
to
habitats and biodiversity it's estimated
we've lost 3 billion birds in north
america in recent years
and insect populations have plummeted as
well
and
you might say well that's great for
great by me i don't like bugs
but
that's what the amphibians eat that's
what the birds eat that's a vital part
of our food chain
and
why are we losing insects
what are we doing to the planet that's
resulting in the loss of insects that's
a an even more compelling issue so we
we're very focused on education
i was so proud when the very first year
that we launched our
client climate change and health
certificate program we had three nurses
they were all from
mass general
and i asked them
um when i had an opportunity why are you
taking this course they said well we're
the three people who care the most about
climate change in the nursing school at
harvard we all happen to be a mass
general we're all helping each other
we're going to take your curriculum and
we're going to work it into the nursing
curriculum of harvard university and i
just was the happiest man
because um to me that was the whole
point of the climate change certificate
and now we have it as a mooc
a mass
online
something what does moog stand for
course of course
somebody knows
mass
mass online something course
uh open course open
mass online open course and that's i i i
can't remember it's free or if it's 49
bucks but it's
incredibly cheap and that's pretty much
everything here without the love and
attention and we have our
new climate change and health
concentration in our in our mph we have
an emphasis in our executive online mph
so
we even have people who live in milford
and and madison who are taking this just
because so much easier when they're
working professionals but then we've got
people in california and louisiana and
elsewhere and then um we're doing k-12
outreach for education in our schools a
lot of community outreach talks
to all sorts of audiences i gave a talk
to the connecticut arborists
the people who chop down trees by you
know and
replant them and you know
somebody had heard me talk and they
asked me to give a talk so i schlepped
up to west harvard and met the arborists
and and any anybody else who wants to
hear about this now
you happen to be in an center of
expertise right here in this building
you can read about it on your own
website
and
you spearheaded this graduate forum and
global youth summit just last year
dean kurth co-chairs the sustainability
committee
she's one of three deans on that
committee and she's a leader yale and
nationwide in this space and i'm not
kidding she
literally
educated the president of our university
and that's why planetary health is one
of our major priorities
it was it was deemed a major priority by
the
um
by scott strobel's old science committee
but it was not well it was not well
packaged it was not well presented and
ant fixed all of that almost
single-handedly and then associated
nelson spearheads planetary health in
its global context
being the associate dean for
global health and planetary health
something like that
i wanted to mention jodie sherman in the
work she's doing on health care
environmental sustainability those of
you who are deeply engaged in hospital
care which is a number of you
this is very much focused on the fact
that if
the hospitals and healthcare
environments of the world were a country
they would be the 11th
largest greenhouse gas emitter
so the healthcare industry itself is one
of the worst offenders in terms of
greenhouse gas emission
and that's because we use it once and
throw it away
that's because we have our anesthetic
gases which were pumping and only three
percent is metabolized and 97 is
re-released
and on and on and on all sorts of
reasons you want to get active call jody
she is a force of nature and doing very
fine work uh out of the school of public
health in the medical school and working
also at the end
and many other nursing resources
yesterday or day before i did a pubmed
search i found
775 just just for climate change and
nursing that's all i did simplest search
in the world
and nearly half of them were from the
from the last three years
and i found a couple from ann
uh in the journal of nursing scholarship
two of them and
i also found this collaboration
of the alliance of nurses for healthy
environments and its nurses climate
challenge i accidentally put a an
apostrophe they don't have an apostrophe
nurses climate challenge initiative
collaborating with health without harm
and these are a couple of resources
there so
nurses are at the forefront of the
demand that we do something about this
and i think public health people are too
i'd like to get our medical schools on
board i'd like to get our universities
on board and we can actually make a
difference so thank you for your
attention a few uh sites from our site
and
looking forward to t
so who who wants to talk about ukraine
or nuclear power or any other topic
any questions or comments please
yes
okay so i'm i'm an old-fashioned guy and
i saw the china syndrome and i lived
through three mile island and chernobyl
and if you ask me do i want to live next
to a nuclear power plant i'd say no
thank you
on the other hand
nuclear power is um very benign from a
greenhouse gas emissions point of view
you produce a vast amount of energy with
no greenhouse gas emissions i'm not
saying that the process doesn't have
some greenhouse gas emissions but it's a
tiny tiny fraction and you generate vast
amounts of energy
one massive problem well two two
problems one is safety three mile island
chernobyl fukushima
but the other is where do you put the um
the uh spent nuclear fuel which still is
radioactive for the next 30 000 years or
whatever
and we thought we had a plan for yucca
mountain
which was vetted for 50 years
as a highly
stable mountain seismically inactive a
natural
depth
and a place that you literally could
store
and the um
the nevada
senators and congress persons were too
powerful
and they put a kibosh and president
obama abandoned the yucca mountain plan
and now we're storing it all over the
place
san onofre in california not far from
where i went to high school
is storing all of their nuclear waste
right there
on site
and they've walled it off and they've
got it but it's it's sitting there near
the pacific ocean
and you know all these experts are
saying oh it can stand the big one the
big the big quake i don't believe that
for a second so
they're storing it there because they
have nowhere to take it
so if we were serious about nuclear we
would have to get very serious about
issues like
if you're going to put this near a w
near water because you have to have the
cooling so you have to put these near
water or you have to have water
available then you better think about a
tsunami
and you better think about
the big the big earthquake in california
you better think about
um
all of the safety considerations so we
need a coherent safety approach and we
need a coherent uh nuclear
disposal approach
but i have changed my mind over the
years i think that the
urgency of the global warming crisis
has to make us rethink nuclear
now i'd much prefer that we reduce our
energy consumption i'd much prefer that
we go solar and electric i'd much prefer
many other things but i think we're
going to need nuclear too
now the french have shown it can be done
safely the french have had the highest
proportion of nuclear power in their
grid of any country in the western world
or i think any country anywhere
and they have never had a nuclear
accident
but their
nuclear
waste storage is still suboptimal
so that's what i personally think about
nuclear
yes
please short-term planning versus
long-term planning and i wondered if you
had any examples of whether that be you
know domestically or abroad of people
who are doing a good job of saying like
okay we need to look at the 40-year plan
the 50-year plan as opposed to you know
like the four-year you know political
elected office term
well um
i might pluck out the danes
so the danes figured they there was a
big problem 30 years ago
and they invested massively in a
resource that they have a lot of other
people don't have which is known as the
north sea wind
and uh i think the second largest wind
farm in the world
is off the coast of denmark
and it's in a part where there's it's
out literally in the north sea not where
they're in intense bird populations
and uh they figured out the technology
of of how to seat the wind farm into the
into the sea
and how to harvest the energy by
bringing it you know subterranean back
to land
and um
i wish i could remember the proportion
of all the energy grid in denmark that's
from wind but it's a really high number
like 30 or something and this is a test
of concept there they proved it could be
done
i have been to um
xinjiang province
the province with a majority uighur
population in northeast china
now there is tremendous
political disruption and discrimination
and harm being done to the uyghurs in
that part of china but before that i had
a project there
and i went through the largest wind
tunnel and this was between two mountain
chains they took advantage of the
natural wind that was
feeding this
big valley they built
a wind farm that was further than the
eye could see
all with modern wind technology
so there's a lot that can be done with
wind
solar
technology has improved massively
and we have some examples in our own
country of highly successful
solar
strategies but i think where i'm
most disturbed is when i go visit my son
my younger son who lives in orlando and
i just see so few solar panels and this
is like you think about florida
you think about arizona
and then think about
chad
and niger and mali
and some of the poorest countries of the
world
and think about all the wasted
energy
by not harvesting the sun
in these sun intensive venues and why
can't we have a global campaign
not to mention covet vaccine but but to
mention um solar panels in
in
high
sun zones you know this is this is uh
this is uh cherry picking
something that would be relatively
straightforward because fewer solar
panels would be more efficient
in high sun regions but even in low sun
regions even in a cloudy day you can
harvest energy from a solar panel
now i was personally disappointed with
the blind administration decision
because i'm at the point in my
awareness of this problem that i
i feel that uh
we can't be compromising at every turn
uh if we say that federal lands are not
going to be used for oil exploitation
then we stick to it and if we have a
problem with um
with um gasoline prices being too high
we look the people in the eye on
television and we say
do you have a bus that goes from your
home to your work
or a train
could you call a neighbor can you
cut your or your gasoline prices by um
by carpooling
what can you do to help the ukrainian
people at this time without our
sacrificing our grandchildren's future
in a in a warm world
and why can't we call on the american
people for a wartime response
and and and draw on us for
inconveniencing ourselves
and reducing our dependence on oil by by
conservation that's what i would have
liked to hear from the white house not
okay we'll open up
180
000 acres of land i forget how much it
was for oil exploitation which we're not
even going to get that oil for two three
years
so to me that was a very cynical
bid to win votes
i hate to say it that's what i think
stan always says what do you think
i just had a question um
[Music]
electric
batteries which
also produce waste and also increases
the demand for certain ships that are
needed for these kind of electric cars
mainly our mine from um
violation so what are your thoughts
regarding the reconciliation because now
i'm moving towards electric some people
may see it more like maybe under
privilege
and um also the side effect of these
electric battery waste that in the long
run it kind of
what um thoughts have been that they
kind of reflect them back to these um
lower income countries that already are
bearing a branch of like the first
channel
very legitimate and important point
i have been to many uh oil-rich
countries in
africa
in particular
and i've seen
vast income
with very little benefit to the people
angola gabon
nigeria i've seen vast exploitation of
humans in the oil industry and i've also
seen a tremendous pollution impact
in these settings so i'm not saying that
we don't have a problem
with uh rare earths and minerals that
are required for nickel and the like and
and battery production
uh congo is one of the major producers
china is another one of the major
producers
so i think yes we have a
problem
in consumption
of
of products
that are often
yielded from an environment like russia
which now uses oil money to wage war on
the ukrainians
so
there is a challenge
on both sides of the equation
on the
battery
power needed for electric cars
and for the oil and gas needed for the
fossil fuel consuming cars
so i think one would need a more
more
complex analysis shall we say
of of overall harms
now
can we demand that
tesla and gm and ford
source their materials
the way that we've tried to demand that
global diamond manufacturers source
their materials the blood diamonds are
not permitted and
they have to be tracked et cetera so
there may be mitigating elements that we
can do in the sourcing of these
materials so we don't have the choice
between
abusing congolese children and
climate change related catastrophe 50
years from now so i think i think we
have to resolve i have to recognize them
as you have done
address them
and resolve them and that would be my
choice
rather than say ah forget electric we'll
go with the we'll go with the gas stuff
because
you know won't hurt congolese children
well it's going to hurt nigerian
children it's going to hurt gabanese
children and angolan children so it's
it's it's i'm not saying it's a wash
because i'm not expert enough in the
topic to comment but that would be the
way i think about it
thank you
well i would like now to do the other
part of this annual um tradition which
is the whisser tea i'm gonna invite all
of that reception the tea for stem
no red meat
[Laughter]
they try not to use red meat in what we
offer
and i want to also thank of course mean
emerson lord langford um olivia and
jaleesa everyone who wants to put this
together today thank you and most of all
[Applause]
because of the movies they're a little
too big to email but they're on box sent
to ann's office and they're on this
computer anybody who can use any of
these slides for any purpose please do
thank you